the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so we are going to continue looking
at what happens when we have
non-independent variables so I am afraid
we don't take Delhi phase joint last I'm
sorry okay let's take a seat
Thanks oh no thanks
okay
okay so Jason you please claim your
package at the end of lecture ok so last
time we saw how to use Lagrange
multipliers to find the minimum or
maximum of a function of several
variables when the variables are not
independent and today we are going to
try to figure out more about relations
between variables and how to handle
functions that depend on several
variables when they are related so just
to give you an example in physics
variable very often you have functions
that depend on pressure volume and
temperature where pressure of volume and
temperature are actually not independent
but they are related say by PV equals
NRT so of course when you can substitute
and express the function in terms of two
of them only but very often it's
convenient to keep all three but then we
have to figure out what are the rates of
change of P and V with respect to T with
respect to each other the rate of change
of F with respect to these variables and
so on so we have to figure out what we
mean by partial derivatives again so
okay I mean marginally let's say just
for the sake of notation I'm going to
think of a function of three variables X
Y Z where the variables are related by
some equation that they will put up a
form in the form G of X Y Z equals some
constant ok so that's the kind of same
kind of setup as we had last time except
now we are not just looking for minima
and Maxima we are trying to understand
partial derivatives
so the first observation is that you
know if X Y & Z are related then that
means in principle we could solve for
one of them and express it as a function
of the two of us
so in particular can we understand even
without solving maybe we cannot solve
can we understand how the variables are
related to each other so if for example
Z you can think of Z as a function of x
and y so we can ask ourselves what are
the rate of change of Z with respect to
X keeping Y constant or with respect to
Y keeping X constant and of course if we
can solve then we know from your F of s
and then we can compute these guys but
what if we can't solve so how do we find
these things without solving well so
let's do an example let's say that my
relation is x squared plus y Z plus Z
cubed equals 8 and let's say that I'm
looking near the point X Y Z equals to a
1 so let me check 2 squared plus 3 times
1 plus 1 cubed is indeed 8 okay but now
if I change x + y a little bit how does
Z change well of course I could solve
for Z in here it's a cubic equation
there is actually a formula but that
formula is quite complicated we actually
don't want to do that there's an easier
way
so how can we do it well let's look at
the differential of this constraint
quantity okay so if we call this G let's
look at DG so well what's the
differential of this so differential of
x squared is 2x DX plus I think there's
a z dy there's a wide easy and there's
also a 3z squared DZ you can get this
either by implicit differentiation and
the product whole or you can get this
just by putting here here and here the
partial derivatives of this with respect
to XY and z ok any questions about how I
got this No ok so now what do I do with
this well this represents somehow
variations of G but well I've set this
thing equal to 8 and 8 is a constant so
it doesn't change so in fact well we can
set this to zero because well they call
this G then G equals 8 is constant that
means we set DG equal to zero okay so
now let's just plug in some values at
this point
that tells us well so if x equals two
that's for the X plus Z is 170 y plus y
plus KZ square should be six DZ equals
zero and now this equation here tells us
about a relation between the changes in
x y&z near that point it tells us how if
you change X&Y well how Z will change or
it tells you actually anything you might
want to know about the relations between
these variables so for example you can
you know move DZ to that side and then
express DZ in terms of DX and dy or you
can move the Y to that side and X PRIZE
dy in terms of DX and DZ and so on it
tells you add value of the derivatives
how each of the variables depends on the
two of us okay so just to clarify this
if we want to view Z as a function of x
and y then what we will do is we'll just
move the disease to the other side and
it will tell us DZ equals minus 1 over 6
times 4 DX plus dy and so that should
tell you that partial Z over partial X
is minus 4 over 6 well that's minus 2/3
and partial Z over partial Y is going to
be minus 1/6
another way to think about this when we
compute partial Z over partial X that
means that actually we keep Y constant
okay let me actually add some subtitles
here so here that means we keep Y
constant and so if we keep Y constant
another way to think about it is we set
dy to 0 we set dy equals 0 so if we do
that we get DX equals negative 4 6 DX
that tells us the rate of change of Z
with respect to X here we set X constant
so that means we set DX equal to 0 and
if we set DX equal to 0 when we have DZ
equals negative 1/6 of dy that tells us
the rate of change of Z with respect to
Y ok any questions about that nope
what yes
yes okay let me explain that again so we
found an expression for D Z in terms of
DX and dy that means that this thing is
the differential is the total
differential of Z viewed as a function
of x and y ok and so the coefficients of
DX and dy are the partials
another way to think about it if you
want to know partial Z partial X it
means you set Y to be constant setting Y
to be constant means that you will put 0
in the place of dy so you'll be left
with DZ equals -4 X DX and that will
give you the rate of change of Z with
respect to X when you keep Y constant
okay so various ways to think about this
but hopefully it makes sense ok so how
do we think about this in general well
if we know that G of X Y Z equals
constant then DG which is G sub X DX
plus G sub y dy plus G sub Z DZ should
be set equal to 0 and now we can solve
for whichever variable we want to
express in terms of variables so for
example if we care about Z as a function
of x and y its
we'll get that DZ is negative G sub X
over G sub Z DX sorry minus G sub y over
G is a busy dy and so if we want partial
Z over partial X well so one way is just
to say that's going to be the
coefficient of DX in here or just to
write down the other way we are setting
y equals constant so that means we set
dy equal to zero okay and then we get DZ
equals negative G sub X over G sub Z DX
so that means partial Z over partial X
is minus GX over GZ and see that's a
very counterintuitive formula because
you have this minus sign that you
somehow probably couldn't have seen come
you know if you hadn't actually derived
things this way
I mean it's it's pretty surprising to
see that minus sign come out of nowhere
the first time you see it but okay so
now we know how to find the rate of
change of constrained variables with
respect to each other you can apply the
same to find you know if you want
partial X partial Y or any of them you
can do it any questions so far
No
okay so before we proceed further I
should probably
expose some problem with annotations
that we have so far so let me try to get
you a bit confused okay so let's take a
very simple example let's say I have a
function f of X y equals x plus y ok so
far doesn't sound very confusing and
then I can write partial F over partial
X and I think you all know how to
compute it it's going to be just one ok
so far we are pretty happy now let's do
a change of variables let's set x equals
u and y equals u plus V it's not a very
complicated change of variables but
let's do it then
f in terms of U and V well so f remember
was X plus y becomes u plus u plus V
that's twice u plus V what's partial F
over partial U it's two so X and u are
the same thing
partial F over partial X and partial F
over partial U well unless you believe
that one equals two they are really not
the same thing ok so that's an
interesting slightly strange phenomenon
x equals u but partial F partial X is
not the same as partial F partial U
so how do we get rid of this
contradiction well we have to think a
bit more about what these notations mean
okay so when we write partial F over
partial X it means that we are varying X
keeping Y constant when we write partial
F over partial u it means we are varying
you keeping V constant so varying you
are varying X is the same thing but
keeping V constant or keeping Y constant
under the same thing if I keep Y
constant then when I change X so when I
change u then we will also have to
change so that there's some stays the
same or if you prefer the other way
around
when I do this when I keep V constant if
I keep V constant and I change U then Y
will change it won't be constant so that
means well life looked quite nice and
easy with these notations but what's
dangerous about them is they're not
making explicit what it is exactly that
we are keeping constant okay so just to
write things so here we change U and X
by the same thing but we keep Y constant
while here we change U which is still
the same thing as X but what we keep
constant is V or in terms of X and Y
that's Y minus X constant and that's why
they are not the same so whenever
there's any risk of confusion okay so
not in the cases that we had before
because you know in what we've done
until now we don't really have any
problem but in a situation like this to
clarify things will actually say
explicitly what it is that we want to
keep constant
okay so what's going to be our new
notation well so it's not particularly
pleasant because it uses now a subscript
not to indicate what you're
differentiating but rather what you're
holding constant so that's quite a
conflict of notation with what we had
before I think I can safely blame it on
physicists or chemists so okay so this
one means we keep Y constant and partial
F over partial U with v held constant
similarly okay so now what happens is we
no longer have any contradiction we have
partial F over partial X with Y constant
is different from partial F over partial
X with v constant which is the same as
partial F over partial U with v constant
okay so this guy is one and these guys
now - so now we can safely use the fact
that x equals u if we are keeping track
of what is actually held constant okay
so now that's going to be particularly
important when we have variables that
are related because let's say now that I
have a function that depends on x y&z
but x y&z are related then it means that
you know if I look at say X and y as my
independent variables and Z as a
function of x and y then it means that
when I do partials say with respect to X
I will hold Y constant but I will let Z
vary as a function of X and why
I could do it the other way around I
could very ex keep Z constant and let Y
be a function of X and Z and so I will
need to use this kind of notation to
indicate which one I need
okay any questions nope alright so let's
try to do an example where we have a
function that depends on variables that
are related okay so I don't want to do
one with PV equals NRT because probably
I mean if you've seen it when you've
seen too much of it and if you haven't
seen it then maybe it's not the best
example so let's do a geometric example
okay so let's look at the area of the
triangle so let's say I have a triangle
and my variables will be the sides a and
B and the angle here theta okay so
what's the array of this triangle well
its base times height over two so it's
one half of the bases a and the height
is B sine theta okay so that's a
function of a B and theta now let's say
actually there's a relation between a B
and theta that I didn't tell you about
namely actually I want to assume that
it's a right triangle okay so let's now
assume it's a right triangle
with let's say the hypotenuse is B so we
have a right angle here actually so a is
here B is here theta is here so saying
that it's a right triangle is the same
thing as saying that a equals B cosine
theta okay so that's our constraint
that's the relation between a B and
theta and this is a function of a B and
theta and let's say that we want to
understand how the area depends on theta
what's the rate of change of the area of
this triangle with respect to theta so I
claim there's various answers I can
think of at least three possible answers
so what can we possibly mean by the rate
of change of a with respect to theta so
these are all things that we might want
to call partial a partial theta but of
course we'll have to actually use
different notations to you know
distinguish them so the first way that
we actually already know about is if we
just forget about the fact that the
variables are related okay so if we just
think of little a B and theta as
independent variables and we just change
theta keeping a and B constant
so that's exactly what we meant by
partial a partial theta right we are not
putting any constraint so just to use
some new notation that would be the rate
of change of a with respect to theta
keeping a and B fixed at the same time
of course if we are keeping a and B
fixed and we are changing theta
it means we completely ignore this
property of being a right triangle so in
fact it corresponds to changing the area
by changing the angle keeping these
lengths fixed and of course we lose the
right angle when we rotate this side
here then the angle doesn't stay right
angle and that when we know how to
compute right because it's the one we've
been computing all along so that means
we keep a and B fixed and then so let's
see what's the derivative of a with
respect to theta I get hits one-half a B
cosine theta okay but when we know any
questions
nope okay the two of our guys would be
more interesting
so far I'm not really doing anything
with my constraint let's say that
actually I do want to keep a right angle
then when I change theta there's two
options one is I keep a constant and
then of course B will have to change
because if this width stays the same
then when I change theta the height
increase and then this side length
increases the other option is I change
the angle keeping be constant so
actually this side stays the same length
but when a has to become a bit shorter
and of course VR a will change in
different ways depending on what I do so
that's why I say we have three different
answers so the next one is keep I forgot
which one I said first let's say keep a
constant and that means that B will
change B is going to be some function of
a and theta well in fact here we know
what the function is because we can
solve the constraint namely B is a over
cosine theta but we don't actually need
to know that so that the triangle so
that the right angle so that we keep a
right angle
and so the name we will have for this is
partial a of a partial theta with a held
constant okay and the fact that I'm not
putting be in my subscript there means
that actually B will be a dependent
variable it changes in whatever way it
has to change so that when theta changes
a stays the same well B changes so that
we keep a right triangle
and the third guy is the one where we
actually keep the constant and now a we
think of a as a function of B and theta
and it changes so that we keep a right
angle this actually as a function of B
and theta it's given over it's given
about a equals B cosine theta and so
this guy is called partial a of a
partial theta with be held constant okay
so we've just defined them we don't know
yet how to compute these things that's
what we're going to do now that is the
definition and what these things mean is
that clear to everyone yes okay yes okay
so the second answer again so one way to
ask ourselves how does the area depend
on theta is to say well we'll actually
look at the area of a right triangle as
a function of a and theta only by
solving for B and then we'll change
theta keep a constant and ask how does
the area change so when we do that when
we change theta and keep a the same then
B has to change so that it stays a right
triangle right so that this relation
still holds that requires us to change B
so when we write partial a of a partial
theta with a constant it means that
actually B will be the dependent
variable it depends on a and theta and
so the area depends on theta not only
because theta is in the formula but also
because B changes and B is in the
formula yes no no we don't keep radar
constant with very fader right the goal
is to see how things change when I
change theta by a little bit okay so if
I change theta a little bit in this one
if I change theta a little bit and I
keep a the same then B has to change
also in some way so that it stays a
right triangle and then because theta
and B change that causes the area to
change okay so maybe I should have
explained that within so theta changes a
is constant but we have the constraint a
equals B cosine theta that means that B
changes and then the question is how
does a change well it will change in
part because theta changes and in part
because B changes but we want to know
how it depends on theta in this
situation yes
that's a very good question so what
about I don't keep a and B constant well
when there's too many choices so I have
to decide actually how I'm going to
change things
C if I just say I have this relation
that means I have two independent
variables left whichever two of the
three I want but I still have to specify
two of them to say exactly which
triangle I mean so I cannot ask myself
just how will it change if I change
theta and do random things with a and B
it depends what I do with a and B of
course I could choose to change them
simultaneously but then I have to
specify how exactly I'm going to do that
I guess if you wanted to indeed we could
also change things in such a way that
the third side remains constant and that
would be yet a different way to attack
the problem I mean we don't have a good
notation for this here because we didn't
give it a name but yeah I mean we could
you know we could call this guy C and
then we'd have a different formula and
so on so I mean I'm not looking at it
for simplicity but you could have many
more I mean in general you will want you
know once you have a set of nice natural
variables you will want to look mostly
at situations where one of the variable
changes some of them are held fixed and
then some dependent variable does
whatever it must so that the constraint
keeps keeps holding okay so let's try to
compute one of them let's say I decide
that we'll compute this one let's see
how we can compute partial a partial
theta with a held fixed
okay so let's try to compute partial a
partial theta with a held constant so
let's see three different ways of doing
that so let me start with method zero
okay it's not a real method that's why
I'm not giving it a positive number so
that one is just we solve for B and we
plug we remove B from the formulas okay
so here it works well because we know
how to solve for B but I'm not
considering this to be a real method
because in general we don't know how to
do that I mean if we use you know in the
beginning I had this relation that was
an equation of degree three
you don't really want to solve your
equation for the dependent variable
usually here we can so solve for B and
substitute so how do we do that well the
constraint is a equals B cosine theta
that means B is a over cosine theta some
of you know that as a second theta
that's the same and now if we express
the area in terms of a and theta only a
is one half of a be cosine so a B sine
theta is now one half of a squared sine
theta over cosine theta or if you prefer
one half of a square tangent theta
well now that it's only a function of a
and theta I know what it means to take
the partial derivative with respect to
theta keeping a constant I know how to
do it so partial a over partial theta
with a held constant well if a is a
constant when I get this 1/2 a squared
coming out times what's the derivative
of tangent second squared
very good if you're European and you've
never heard of secant that's one of our
cosine and if you know the derivative as
one plus tangent squared that's the same
thing and it's also going okay so that's
one way of doing it but as I've already
said it doesn't get us very far if we
don't know how to solve for B I mean we
really use the fact that we can solve
for B and get rid of it so there's two
systematic methods and let's say the
basic role is that you should give both
of them a chance you should see which
one you prefer and you should be able to
use one of one of the other on the exam
okay most likely you will actually have
a choice between one or the other
will be up to you to decide which one
you want to use but you cannot use
solving and substitution that's not fair
okay so the first one is to use
differentials
by the way in the notes there call also
method 1 and Method 2 I'm not promising
that I have the same one I mean I might
have one and two switched it doesn't
really matter so how do we do things
using differentials
well first we know that we want to keep
a fixed and that means that we'll set da
equal to zero the second thing that we
want to do is we long we want to look at
the constraint the constraint is a
equals B cosine theta and we want to
differentiate that well differentiate
the left hand side you get da and
differentiate the right hand side as a
function of B and theta
you should get well how many DB's well
that's rate of change with respect to B
but cosine theta DB minus B sine theta D
theta that's the product rule apply to B
times cosine theta so
well now if we have a constraint that's
relating da DB and D theta okay so
that's actually what we did right that's
the same same sort of thing as what we
did at the beginning when we related DX
dy and DZ that's really the same thing
except now our variables are a B and
theta now we know that also we are
keeping a fixed so actually we set this
equal to 0 so we have 0 equals da equals
cosine theta DB minus B sine theta D
theta that means that actually we know
how to solve for D B okay so cosine
theta D B equals B sine theta D theta or
D B is B tangent theta D theta so in
fact what we found if you want is the
rate of change of B with respect to
theta why do we care
well we care because let's look now at
da the function that we want to look at
okay so the function is a equals 1/2 a B
sine theta
well then da so we have to use the
product rule carefully or we use the
partials so the coefficient of D little
a will be partial expect too little a
that's 1/2 B sine theta da plus
coefficient of D B will be 1 half a sine
theta GB plus coefficient of D theta
will be 1/2 ad cosine theta D theta
okay but now what do I do with that well
first I said a is constant so da is 0
second while we actually we don't like B
at all right we want to view a as a
function of theta so well maybe we
actually want to use this formula for DB
that we found in here okay and then
we'll be left only with D theta which is
what we want
so if we plug this one into that one
we get the a equals 1/2 a sine theta
times B tangent theta D theta plus 1/2 a
B cosine theta D theta and if we collect
these things together we get 1/2 of a B
times sine theta times tangent theta
plus cosine theta D theta and if you
know your trig then you will see that
this is sine squared over cosine plus
cosine squared over cosine that's the
same as second theta so now you have
expressed da as something times D theta
well that coefficient is the rate of
change of a with respect to theta with
the understanding that we are keeping a
fixed and letting be very as a dependent
variable not enough space all right
okay
in case it's clearer for you let's think
about it backwards so we wanted to find
how it changes to find how a changes we
write da but now this tells us how a
depends on little a little B and theta
well we know which do we want to keep
little a constant so we set this to the
zero theta well we are very happy
because we want to express things in
terms of theta DB we want to get rid of
how do we get rid of DB well we do that
by figuring out how B depends on theta
when a is fixed and we do that by
differentiating the constraint equation
and setting da equal to zero okay so
we I guess to summarize the method we
vote da in terms of DA DB D theta then
we say that a is constant means we set
da equals 0 and the third thing is that
because well we differentiate the
constraint and we can solve for DB in
terms of D theta and then we plug in to
DA and we get the answer
okay oops
so here's another method to do the same
thing differently is to use the chain
rule so we can use the chain rule with
dependent variables okay so what does
the chain of all tell us the chain rule
tells us so we will want to
differentiate the formula for a with
respect to theta holding a constant so I
claim well what does the chain rule tell
us it tells us that well when we change
things it changes because of the changes
in the variables so part of it is that a
depends on theta and theta changes how
fast the theta change well you could
call that the rate of change of theta
with respect to theta with a constant
but of course how fast does theta depend
on itself the answer is 1 so that's
pretty easy plus then we have this the
partial derivative the formal partial
derivative of a with respect to little a
times the rate of change of a in our
situation
well how does little a change if a is
constant well it doesn't change and then
there's a sub little B reform or partial
derivative times so the rate of change
of B ok and how do we find this one well
here we have to use the constraint ok
and we can find this one from the
constraint as we've seen at the
beginning either by differentiating the
constraint or by using the chain rule on
the constraint so of course the
calculations are exactly the same see
this is the same formula as the one over
we're just dividing everything by
for theta and with subscript little a
but if you you know it's easier for you
think about it this way then that's also
valid okay so tomorrow we are going to
review for the test so I'm going to tell
you a bit more about this also as we go
over one practice problem on that